POLGLASE REPORTS, THERE IS NOT A
SHRED OF EVIDENCE TO SUPPORT THE
RUSSIAN' TAKE.
>> Reporter: KHARKIV.
MELITOPOL.
NOW, MARIUPOL.
DESPITE BEING AN APPARENT WAR
CRIME, MEDICAL FACILITIES HAVE
BEEN REPEATEDLY HIT BY RUSSIA
SINCE ITS INVASION OF UKRAINE.
AND WITH EACH HIT, A NEW
JUSTIFICATION.
FROM MARIUPOL, RUSSIA SET THE
STAGE DAYS BEFORE THE ATTACK
HAPPENED.
>> ARMED FORCES OF UKRAINE HAVE
SET UP A FIRE POSITION THERE.
>> EXPELLED THE STAFF AND
PATIENTS FROM THE MATERNITY
HOSPITAL AND EQUIPPED COMBAT
POSITIONS IN IT.
>> Reporter: CNN HAS FOUND ZERO
EVIDENCE SUCH MILITARY POSITIONS
WERE PRESENT AT MARIUPOL'S
MATERNITY AND CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL ON THE AFTERNOON OF
MARCH 9th, AND IT WAS CIVILIANS
THAT EMERGED FROM THE BUILDINGS.
PREGNANT WOMEN, INJURED AND
DISTRESSED.
CITY OFFICIALS SAY 17 PEOPLE,
INCLUDING CHILDREN, WOMEN, AND
DOCTORS WERE INJURED.
SINCE THEN, AT LEAST FIVE PEOPLE
HAVE DIED.
CNN BUILT A MODEL THAT REVEALED
MANY SIGNS THAT CIVILIANS WERE
STILL USING THIS HOSPITAL AND,
THEREFORE, IT WAS NOT A
JUSTIFIABLE MILITARY TARGET.
THIS SATELLITE IMAGE TAKEN JUST
HOURS BEFORE THE ATTACK SHOWS
CARS PARKED OUTSIDE.
THIS IS THE CRATER LEFT BEHIND.
WAR CRIME INVESTIGATOR TRUTH
HOUNDS TOLD CNN STS CONSISTENT
WITH A 500 KILOGRAM HIGH
EXPLOSIVE BOMB DROPPED FROM AN
AIRCRAFT.
JUST METERS AWAY, THIS SIGN
READS "CHILDREN'S DIAGNOSTIC
CONSULTANCY UNIT."
ACCORDING TO THE HOSPITAL
WEBSITE, IT HOUSED CHILDREN WITH
IMMUNE DISEASES, AMONG OTHER
ILLNESSES.
OVER HERE IS WHERE PEOPLE BEGAN
EMERGING AFTER THE STRIKE.
WOMEN, HEAVILY PREGNANT, BEING
CARRIED WITH ARMS DRAPED OVER
THE SHOULDERS OF OTHERS HELPING
THEM GET OUT OF THE CHAOS.
AND HERE, FIREMEN CAN BE SEEN
RUNNING INSIDE ASSISTING PEOPLE
TO ESCAPE.
THE INTERNAL DEVASTATION IS SIG
THINK CAN'T.
THE VOICE YOU ARE HEARING IS ONE
OF THE SURVIVORS SPEAKING TO
ASSOCIATED PRESS WHO GAVE BIRTH
SHORTLY AFTER.
ANOTHER SEEN HERE BEING
STRETCHERED OUT LATER DIED
ALONGSIDE HER NEWBORN BABY.
THESE WOMEN'S STORIES HAVE
EPITOMIZED THE TRAGEDY UNFOLDING
IN UKRAINE.
AND YET, EVEN THEIR SUFFERING
HAS BEEN QUESTIONED WITH RUSSIAN
OFFICIALS CLAIMING ON TWITTER
AND IN NEWS PROGRAMS THAT THEY
MUST BE ACTORS.
>> THIS IS ONLY ONE WOMAN
RUSHING DOWN THE STAIRWELL.
HERE, SHE CHANGED CLOTHES AND
SHE HAS BEEN BROUGHT ON THE
STRETCHER.
>> YOU ARE SHOWING THIS TO ME
BUT IF YOU HAVE ANY REAL
EVIDENCE --
>> YES, THIS IS REAL EVIDENCE.
>> WHY DID YOU SHOW IT TO ME?
I AM JUST A JOURNALIST IN THE
NETHERLANDS.
WHY DIDN'T YOU SHOW IT TO THE
UNITED NATIONS?
>> WHILE RUSSIAN FOREIGN
MINISTER LAVROV RETURNED TO THE
ORIGINAL LINE, THIS ATTACK WAS
JUSTIFIED.
>> Translator: THIS MATERNITY
HOSPITAL HAD ALREADY BEEN SEIZED
BY THE AZOV BATTALION AND OTHER
RADICALS.
ALL THE PREGNANT WOMEN, ALL THE
NURSES, ALL THE SERVICE
PERSONNEL WERE ALREADY EXPELLED
FROM THERE.
>> Reporter: AS THESE ATTACKS ON
HOSPITALS, CLINICS, EVEN
AMBULANCES CONTINUE, CNN IS
TRACKING EACH ONE.
IN TOTAL, WE HAVE VERIFIED 14
INCIDENTS ACROSS UKRAINE.
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION,
MEANWHILE, HAS CONFIRMED AT
LEAST 31.
AND WITH EACH HIT, THE ABILITY
OF PEOPLE IN UKRAINE TO